showtimes horror drama penny dreadful
dropped its biggest twist during its
season three finale the blessed dark the
series was over while the show is still
having its last rites read let's
investigate the potentially spoiler
filled mystery of why it had to end
declining viewership the last season of
Penny dreadful was not a ratings
juggernaut clocking out at number six
among show times ten original shows
behind billions and the affair
viewership had dropped over five percent
compared to the previous year while
other shows had fewer viewers penny
dreadfuls elaborate settings and special
effects made it far more expensive to
produce a cult following just wasn't
enough a little over half a million
people watched the series finale live
money like most TV cancellations money
was lovely a large factor in showtimes
decision to give penny dreadful the axe
it happened to plenty of other fan
favorite shows over the years Firefly
Hannibal Constantine and dollhouse among
them despite featuring public domain
characters like Dracula dr. Jekyll
Frankenstein's monster and Dorian Gray
the price of bringing this many monsters
to the screen couldn't have been cheap
Vanessa Ives departure despite all the
interesting character she's met over the
past three years penny dreadful is a
tale about Vanessa Ives the series ended
with her finally finding peace and we'll
never see her tangle with the creature
or Dorian Gray again this sudden ending
is how it was planned
showtimes CEO David Nevins said to
Entertainment Weekly I always knew it
wasn't going to be a really long running
show John Logan made that clear coming
in while there are plenty of tail as you
could tell without her in this dark
world Ives was the focal point of this
show and we couldn't imagine it
continuing without her remember how the
x-files felt without Mulder gross more
monsters without Vanessa Ives penny
dreadful is pretty much just a bunch of
19th century ghouls if that's your thing
you'll be seeing a lot more of them soon
Universal Pictures is launching its own
set of films featuring the most classic
of movie monsters the series began with
Dracula untold in 2014
meanwhile The Mummy reboots starring Tom
Cruise is scheduled for 2017 don't be
surprised if TV executives try bringing
Frank dragon the whole monster squad
back to capitalize on Hollywood digging
them up from their graves it was
foretold there are various reasons why
penny dreadful was cancelled but we're
going to have to go with show creator
John Logan's explanation
apparently he knew this was how the
series would end from the very beginning
but the cast found out halfway through
filming season two and Logan's own words
penny dreadful was always intended to go
for three years exactly so I think we've
told our story well and thank you for
all your support and hanging in there
with us all good things come to an end
sorry Game of Thrones fans you too will
know this sting we're sure you'll see
most of these characters in other forms
soon enough thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you'll miss the most about
penny dreadful